vamos a empezar tomando una matriz a y
digamos que esta matriz es muy general
es digamos de tamaño m por n y vamos a
escribirla en términos de sus vectores
columna es decir esta matriz como primer
columna tenemos a 1 como segunda columna
tenemos al vector a 2 y así
sucesivamente hasta el vector a n muy
bien esta es nuestra matriz a y vamos a
empezar tomándonos un vector b en el
espacio columna de nuestra matriz a y
recordemos que el espacio columna de la
matriz en no es otra cosa más que el
espacio generado por los vectores
columna de nuestra matriz es decir que
cualquier elemento en el espacio columna
es una combinación lineal de estos
vectores columna entonces justamente por
esto que acabamos de decir vamos a
escribir a b como una combinación lineal
de los vectores a1 a2 todos hasta a n
entonces este es una constante x 1 x a 1
más otra constante por a dos más uno
bueno etcétera estamos sumando todos
estos la última constante x cn por aena
y estamos justamente diciendo que x 1 x
2 todos los x van a ser constantes
digamos arbitrarias en en nuestro
espacio de los números reales ok y
entonces esta combinación lineal
mediante la cual yo escribía be la puede
escribir de otra forma esto va a ser
equivalente a que si yo tengo la matriz
digamos con estas columnas a 1 a 2 así
sucesivamente hasta n y si multiplicamos
esta matriz por un vector llamado x 1 x
2 y así hasta x n aquí no se ven mucho
los puntitos ahí está ok está estas dos
expresiones expresiones son equivalentes
y como son equivalentes pues por
supuesto esta multiplicación de esta
matriz por este vector debe ser igual a
b muy bien entonces este
este resultado que de hecho es nada más
un repaso de lo que ya habíamos visto en
otros vídeos me está diciendo que esta
ecuación sí sí el vector de constante de
estas constantes x de las x no es
conocido quiere decir que tenemos al
menos una solución a esto tenemos la
matriz a que multiplica un vector x y
que me da la solución igual a b entonces
esta ecuación en donde x es desconocida
tiene
tiene al menos al menos una solución al
menos una solución podría tener más
verdad muchísimas otras más pero al
menos esta tiene una solución y eso es
porque ve lo estamos considerando en el
espacio columna de nuestra matriz y
entonces qué es lo que estamos diciendo
con con con dibujitos
digamos vamos a hacer una caricatura de
lo que estamos haciendo tenemos aquí rn
este es nuestro espacio rn y sn porque
aquí tenemos este este vector x de n
entradas entonces nuestro vector x ahí
se encuentra en rn y digamos que tenemos
aquí también nuestro espacio nulo que
aquí está el espacio nulo de la matriz a
ok y simplemente para recordar quién es
el espacio nulo el espacio nulo es el
conjunto de vectores que tienen esta
solución a x igual a 0 es decir que al
multiplicarlos por la matriz a nos da el
vector 0 ese es el espacio nulo y
también sabemos ya hemos visto en vídeos
anteriores que pues este es un sub
espacio y por lo tanto por aquí andará
el complemento ortogonal es decir el
espacio nulo de a ortogonal que no es
otra cosa más que el espacio fila verdad
del espacio fila que es el espacio
columna de la matriz transpuesta y estos
dos solo se intersectan en un solo punto
que de hecho es el
y demostramos hace ya como dos vídeos me
parece que podemos escribir cualquier
vector de rn como una suma de dos
vectores es decir vamos a tomarnos un
vector aquí que se llame no se n y vamos
a tomarnos no sea algún otro de aquí que
se llame r cualquier cualquier vector
que se encuentra en rn lo podemos
escribir como una suma de uno que se
encuentra en el núcleo y otro que se
encuentra en el espacio fila de la
matriz que es que es igual al
complemento ortogonal del espacio nulo
muy bien entonces ya con esto dicho y
este esto por supuesto estamos diciendo
que es el espacio fila de a este de aquí
es el espacio fila
espacio fila de la matriz a entonces
vamos a tomarnos un x que sea solución
de ax igual a b es decir tenemos un
vector x tal que a x es igual a de qué
entonces x es solución
es solución aunque quizás debería
escribirlo al revés
vamos a ponerlo de esta forma
digamos x es solución es solución de la
ecuación a x igual a be ok consideremos
eso y entonces estamos diciendo que x se
encuentra en rn ok eso es algo inmediato
verdad aquí lo podemos lo podemos ver x
tiene n coordenadas entonces como x se
encuentra en rn y dijimos que podemos
expresar cualquier vector de rn como una
suma de un elemento que se encuentra
aquí con otro que se encuentre acá
entonces yo puedo escribir a x x x lo
podemos escribir como una suma la suma
de un ere 0 + 1 n 0 y donde habíamos
dicho que r 0 los seres r 0 se encuentra
en nuestro espacio fila de la matriz
y el n 0 en el 0 es igual pero no no es
igual se encuentra en el núcleo de la
matriz ok eso es porque podemos
descomponer cualquier vector de rn de
esta forma entonces qué pasa si nosotros
despejamos a r 0 es decir nosotros vamos
a escribir vamos a pasar digamos
n 0 del lado izquierdo restando y
entonces me queda que r 0 va a ser igual
a x menos n 0 ok muy bien ahora ya aquí
tenemos a r 0 despejado de esta forma
que ocurriría si nosotros multiplicamos
la matriz por r 0 es decir qué pasa si
yo tengo a por r 0 a por r 0 bueno como
r 0 está escrito de esta forma esto va a
ser lo mismo que déjenme hacerlo con
otro color
va a ser que multiplica ere 0 que es x
menos n 0 muy bien y ahora como esta es
una matriz multiplicada una diferencia
de vectores esto no es otra cosa más que
a x menos a por n 0 y ahora vamos a ir
analizando esto dijimos que x era una
solución de x igual a b entonces a x
esto va a ser exactamente b y ahora
quienes a n 0 dijimos que n 0 se
encuentra en el núcleo de la matriz y
nuestra matriz perdona el núcleo es
todos los vectores que al multiplicarlos
por la matriz nos da 0 entonces como
éste está en el núcleo esto no es otra
cosa más que 0 el vector 0 y entonces
está muy bien porque tengo b -0 esto
simplemente es el vector b y déjenme
ponerlo con otro color para que sea más
distinguible ok entonces qué es lo que
hemos obtenido hasta ahorita r 0 r 0 lo
escribí de esta forma y resultó que al
multiplicarlo por la
a medio que era el vector b eso me está
diciendo inmediatamente eso me está
diciendo inmediatamente que r 0 r 0 es
una solución una solución de la de la
ecuación a x igual a ve muy bien
entonces esto es bastante interesante
fíjense nos tomamos inicialmente un b
que se encontrará en el espacio columna
ok ese es un elemento del espacio
columna y con todo esto que hemos
analizado
descubrimos que existe un r 0 r 0 en el
espacio fila verdad aquí está r 0 en el
espacio fila tal que se resuelve esta
ecuación a por x igual a b es decir que
a por r 0 es igual a b entonces esto me
parece un resulta un resultado bastante
interesante y la pregunta inmediata que
surge es bueno será cierto que este ere
0 es único es decir podríamos pensar que
existe algún otro vector
r uno que esté también en el espacio
fila y que también sea solución de esta
ecuación vamos a ver vamos a ver es
decir nos estamos planteando la
posibilidad de si existe consideremos un
r uno que se encuentre en el espacio
fila de la matriz o el espacio columna
de la matriz transpuesta es lo mismo y
que además sea solución y que sea
solución
a la ecuación a x igual a b esto quiere
decir que a por r 1 es igual a b y ya
tenemos este ere 0 que sabemos que
existe vamos a ver qué pasa
bueno lo que podemos empezar haciendo es
tomar una resta de r 1 - r 0 y eso por
qué pues porque como este es un espacio
fila y es un sub espacio vectorial
válido entonces la resta de vectores en
el mismo espacio se queda en el mismo
espacio entonces esto quiere decir que r
1 - r 0 se encuentra exactamente en el
espacio fila de la matriz a ok ahora
bien vamos a ver qué ocurre si
multiplicamos a este vector por la
matriz
entonces si tenemos a que multiplica a r
1 - r 0 esto simplemente como como se
puede distribuir muy bien será a por r 1
menos a porque r 0 y ahora recordemos
que r 1 tanto r 1 como r 0 se encuentran
perdón son soluciones de esta ecuación
entonces a por r uno por un lado es b
esto va a ser b y por el otro lado a por
el resero también va a ser b entonces es
b - b y resulta que esto es 0 es decir
este ere 1 - r 0 resuelve la siguiente
ecuación resuelve a x igual a 0 verdad
es una solución de esta ecuación y eso
inmediatamente me está diciendo qué cosa
pues que de hecho aquí habíamos dicho y
lo habíamos escrito que los vectores que
cumplen esta ecuación a x igual a 0
son aquellos que pertenecen al núcleo o
al espacio nulo de nuestra de nuestra
matriz verdad entonces
es decir que r 1 - r 0 se encuentra en
el espacio nulo de la matriz y esto es
bastante bastante bueno porque si
recordamos aquí tenemos el espacio nulo
y aquí tenemos el espacio ortogonal que
resulta que el espacio ortogonal ya
habíamos dicho que es el espacio fila
del espacio nulo son ortogonales entre
sí entonces aquí tenemos que r 1 - r 0
se encuentra en ambos y dijimos que sólo
existe un único vector que se encuentra
en ambos espacios y ese no es otra cosa
más que el vector 0
entonces como este ere 1 - r 0 se
encuentra en ambos r 1 - r 0 no le queda
otra cosa más que ser el vector 0 verdad
y eso es por este resultado y este otro
resultado pero cierre 1 - r 0 es 0
entonces ya podemos concluir exactamente
que r 1 es igual a 0 verdad pasando r 0
el lado derecho sumando entonces
pensamos que podríamos tener dos
soluciones distintas y al final
concluimos que pues no eran tan
distintas que en realidad eran iguales
entonces qué es lo que hemos obtenido
hasta ahora vamos a ir escribiendo estos
resultados empezamos con un b un vector
b que se encuentra en el espacio columna
de nuestra matriz a ok y lo que llegamos
a concluir a partir de todo esto es que
es que existe existe y de hecho uno solo
es un elemento si no es único un único
elemento
un único elemento de nuestro espacio
fila verdad este r 0 es una solución de
esto pero pero es es un elemento del
espacio fila y déjenme ponerlo con otro
color es un elemento del espacio fila
este es el espacio fila
y este es el espacio fila y de hecho
vamos a escribir bien el nombre digamos
r 0 este ere 0
este ere 0 es el que se encuentra en
nuestro espacio fila de la matriz a ok y
qué ocurre con este ere 0 tal que tal
que ere 0
es solución es solución
es solución de
a x igual ave puede ser eso es cierto
que haya muchísimas otras soluciones de
esta ecuación pero lado sólo existe una
única solución de la ecuación en el
espacio fila y eso es lo más fuerte que
quizás es un un resultado complejo pero
bastante interesante entonces esto
empezamos partimos de tomar un elemento
en el espacio columna escribimos como
combinación lineal y resultaba que era
que lo podíamos escribir de esta forma
como en una ecuación verdad es después
este número es perdón a este vector lo
descomponemos en en una suma donde uno
se encuentra en el espacio fila y el
otro en el espacio nulo y concluimos que
este elemento del espacio fila es
solución y que de hecho es la única
solución en el espacio fila muy bien
entonces vamos a ver qué más podemos
sacar de todo esto vamos a considerar
una solución cualquiera a ax de ok
digamos consideremos cualquier cualquier
solución
solución x
x de a x igual a b y dijimos nuevamente
que como es un elemento de rn lo podemos
descomponer como una suma de dos de dos
vectores verdad un ere cero y un n cero
que se encuentran en estos dos espacios
respectivamente verdad de hecho aquí
aquí es en donde se encuentra el r cero
verdad en el espacio fila es donde
estamos trabajando entonces como lo
podemos escribir de esta forma es decir
puede escribirse puede escribirse
como x igual a 100 más n 0 donde ya
dijimos que erre 0 se encuentra en el
espacio fila o el espacio renglón y n 0
se encuentra en el espacio nulo o que en
el espacio nulo de nuestra matriz vamos
a ver qué pasa con la magnitud de este
vector es decir vamos a considerar la
magnitud
o la norma o la longitud del vector al
cuadrado
quién es esto pues esto simplemente es x
x verdad hacemos el producto punto de x
consigo mismo y es lo que nos da la
norma al cuadrado o la longitud ok al
cuadrado pero esto x se puede
descomponer de esta forma correcto
entonces esto será r 0 más n 0 y déjenme
ponerle sus flechas de vectores punto r
0 más n 0 ok y como sabemos que el
producto punto este puede distribuir
bastante bien esto no es otra cosa más
que r 0.00 0.00 y ahora más
r 0.00 0.00 más
ahora vamos n 0 por r 0 que es lo mismo
que r 0 punto n 0 nuevamente y al final
tenemos n0 punto n 0 en el 0 punto n 0
ok pero observemos muy bien r 0 se
encuentra en el espacio fila y n 0 se
encuentra en el espacio nulo pero
sabemos que esos dos espacios son
ortogonales entre sí entonces estos dos
son ortogonales y por lo tanto su
producto punto es 0 ok entonces esto
simplemente nos quedó como r 0.30 que es
la norma o la magnitud de r 0 al
cuadrado y aquí también tenemos la
magnitud la magnitud de n 0 al cuadrado
ok pero fíjense muy bien
este n 0 a final de cuentas es tiene una
norma mayor o igual que 0 entonces en
realidad este numerito forzosamente
tiene que ser mayor o igual que la norma
de ere 0 al cuadrado y eso es porque
algo positivo le estoy sumando algo
positivo si no se lo sumo pues sería
mucho menor verdad podría ser igual si
si este n 0 es el vector 0 y entonces
éste no contribuye en realidad en nada
podría ser igual pero en términos más
generales este es mucho más grande que
éste verdad a cualquier número si le
sumas otro número pues va a ser mayor o
igual muy bien entonces fíjense muy bien
en que es lo que estamos concluyendo que
si yo partir de una solución cualquiera
su norma al cuadrado de cualquier
solución siempre va a ser mayor o igual
que la norma de ere cero al cuadrado o
que si sacamos raíz cuadrada de ambos
lados tenemos que la magnitud de x es
mayor o igual que la magnitud de r cero
y esto nos está diciendo algo muy
importante porque r cero no
solo es una solución sino que cualquier
otra solución tiene un tamaño mayor es
decir r 0 es la solución más pequeña que
podemos encontrar ok entonces vamos a
escribir ya todo este enunciado
nuevamente empezamos con un vector en el
espacio columna de nuestra matriz a y
decimos que entonces existe existe un r
un único de hecho es un único
r 0 r 0 en el espacio fila de nuestra
matriz tal que qué tal qué tal que r 0
es solución si es solución de nuestra
ecuación a x
igual a b es decir a apure 0 es igual a
b pero no sólo eso que también sabemos
que cualquier otra solución tiene un
tamaño mayor es decir ninguna otra y
ninguna ninguna otra solución
ninguna otra solución
tiene un tamaño menor tiene tamaño menor
tamaño menor es decir si tú me das
cualquier vector b que se encuentra en
el espacio columna en el espacio columna
de la matriz entonces yo te puede
encontrar un único elemento r 0 de
nuestro espacio filia fila que es
esencialmente la solución más pequeña
entendiéndolo como que tiene la longitud
más chica lo cual le parece un resultado
muy bonito y que exploraremos
visualmente en el próximo vídeo